whoa what the hell whoa I don't know
what happened but I love it this is
amazing I'm gonna I'm gonna keep this
we're gonna go with this okay hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to will you press the button
I'm sure you've all played the game
would you rather in some way at home I'm
afraid to move my head or I'm gonna lose
the amazing thing that happened in my
hair but this one's different let me
tell you why because there's always a
catch - everything that if you press
this goddammit if you press the button
your wildest dreams will come true but
there's always a catch on the thing that
beeps guests like this one you will be
able to access the internet with your
mind cool right
but your innermost thoughts will
automatically be posted on your favorite
social media site now see you can figure
out how that be particularly devastating
for me
cuz I sure wouldn't want to put anything
embarrassing on my social media sites
not that I do that already and not that
my innermost thoughts are horrible there
sunshine and rainbows inside my brain
I'm gonna fix this
Jesus the pink is wolf my god the pink
is the pink has a mind of its own
alright okay now that we cut the world's
worst beginning to a let's play out of
the way let's see what I'll do see I
like I said it's not like I'm Hitler
inside my brain it's I just I have some
things that I want to keep private
I'm not Hitler but ok I'm not I will not
I will not good that was a good dilemma
this is funny this is a great let's play
I'm so happy to be able to do ok here we
go
half-life 3 comes out but you can't
plant can only watch little kids playing
without editing oh god it's like the
wit's like my Let's Plays
they're horrible than not Oh No
ok alright so I have to do what you guys
do we just suffer through my stupidity
when I play game oh wow I owe
god ah does that mean the half-life 3
will never come out I don't either
I will not aah oh good people he
believed it oh man that was a good one
geez complete immortality nothing in the
universe can kill you but no one else
will ever be immortal now you see this
is why I like this particular version
because it gets thought-provoking
questions not stupidity like what we've
seen but this has always been like my
philosophy because immortality like
nothing can kill you can you imagine
that like billions and trillions of
years down the road you're still just
floating in blackness probably suffering
and pain from the cold vacuum of space
or you've been sucked inside to the
center of a Sun how horrible would that
be no no I will not I I don't want to
live forever like that geez Wow people
didn't agree with me
whoa really you would want to see
everyone you know and love die that's so
horrible that was good lemma it's good
lemma
you would be a being with demon powers
fighting for good in protecting the
people like all of my favorite animoves
but the more you fight more the more
demonic you become until you abandon
reasoning and only death will Wow that
sounds like an exciting life I mean my
god isn't that the plot of Batman you
live long enough you you you live long
you die oh [ __ ] you live long enough to
see yourself become the hero or you die
no that's too god damn it what you live
long in it [ __ ] I'll press it do it ah
people are disagreeing with me that's
baloney so what if you become a demonic
demon then at least you did good while
you were not and then you give someone
else purpose to defeat you good to love
a good good good dilemma Oh God wait oh
no wait this went this went bigger than
I thought it'd be that's what she said
you're permanently in a relationship
with crush of your dreams and you to
never fall for other people but you have
to be haunted by the grudge for ten
years you will follow you everywhere and
can't leave until a decade has passed ah
I mean okay on the one hand what if
you're / what if my crush is the grudge
lady like his ways the grudge the grudge
lady or is the Brett no that's the ring
the grudge is a kid nevermind we're
putting that aside that's totally no no
no no no okay alright then what I just
who see it says you're permanently in a
relationship with a crush your dreams
but it doesn't say you have a happy
relationship you're just stuck together
what if you're unhappy I mean you could
just have a crush on someone and they
could be totally not the right fit for
you and you have the grudge haunting you
that's horrible Oh unless people think
like the crush of their dreams is like
some celebrities I will not know I have
addend really it was that split
I guess people think that just punching
a grudge in the face would it says the
grudges a she okay what if that wasn't
it but then oh it's a paradox because if
my crush is the grudge she will follow
me for 10 years but then she'll leave in
10 years then she was never gonna be
permanently in a relationship with me is
a jerk I'm too lazy to adness
you can watch any TV show film listen to
any song whenever you want on any device
but the volume will always be really
quiet and you can't have subtitles no
that'd be so but I mean what do you I
mean you can do that Oh Brandon you can
do that already it it exists
this this is irrelevant it's already a
thing I can watch it at whatever ball
you might choose and I choose to blast
my part in full volume from the mid road
you I will not good you will never go to
work again and every week you will be
paid for 40 hours worth of work at
minimum wage but you cannot receive any
of other forms of income or donation
well that's us then I would go out of my
goddamn mind if I didn't have to work I
would be an end at minimum wage that's
horrible
II like that's below the poverty line
that's why I than issues raising the
minimum wage that's getting into a hold
no Katja comments YouTube goddamnit
comments comments come back here stop it
stop it out they're gone comments are
gone sorry
that's a horrible discussion about the
politics money I will no there's no way
Howard how did 40% of the people
how did 40% of people press that how
would you live how would you live I
think my voice is auto-tune pizza you
received five hundred thousand dollars
every year for life but once a year at
random you were kidnapped for a week
oh oh ah how bad is this kidnapping is
it like a Stockholm Syndrome situation
is it the same person kidnapping me
every year is it going to be horrible
he's good could it be fun
could someone kidnap me away for a fun
fun Kayson in Disney World and
I always wanted to go to Disney World
and it's in volando Florida
oh I'm an idiot yeah sure why not let's
see how this goes yeah see what what's
so bad about being kidnapped what what
could happen there get $20 every time
you inhale but every year on your
birthday you have to eat it buckets
would you inhale them which do you
inhale air and then exhale dollars is
that a horrible affliction that you have
to suffer through like every single
breath is it all in ones is it like a is
it like a money shot gun every time you
breathe out needs Wow if you go to a
strip club and you just start breathing
heavy on everyone I'm not gonna finish
that thought I'm okay actually I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay
no I done I've seen a video of a guy eat
a live spider and it's horrifying and
all of the world's problems
famine torture poverty disease etc it's
at several neck
that's bra but you alone suffer all of
them without death for all eternity
ooh now that's interesting would I be
willing to suffer through every problem
that humanity has to offer for all
eternity I don't think any person alive
or has ever been alive would be able to
tolerate that kind of torture but
because this is a hypothetical scenario
it would be really cool if that's how
you know that was my legacy like my
legacy was I bore all of the world's
problems on my shoulders
forever famine torture poverty and
disease and hunger I I guess is also in
there
oh that's famine I I it's like would you
become numb to it do you have every
disease at one every STD possible and
every other disease possible like some
of those
Oh president I'll do it I'll do it I'll
be the hero that Wow only 36 people
press the button babe braver haver you
rule the world and have magic and can
now do anything you want that is
possible realistic or not but no longer
are able to use the Internet is eerie
I'd even though you have all that power
you're not powerful enough to change
this rule okay all right then I'm down
with that
that's amazing you can rule the world
and have magic anything I want to do is
possible I can live without the all the
Internet is is a series of tubes it's
not a big truck that you just dump all
of your stuff on do it's a series of
tubes hell yeah I'm gonna press that
button I can come up with more fun
things to do with my magic yeah everyone
in Detroit dies would I get cake I mean
versus outsid
this is where this is where the deep
dark secrets of my mind get revealed and
the horror that marahau I didn't want my
innermost thoughts it was always just
like boy I hope Detroit just blows up
one day and I really want cake really
I'm not Hitler really run girl later
Italy that's really what goes in my mind
all the time that's really what happens
you living ever to get my brain all the
time Oh Oh God oh it's such a dilemma Oh
God no I really want to see how many
people press the button I bet a lot
really ah now I look like an [ __ ] but
it's probably really good cake I'm sorry
all my fans in Detroit
please join everyone still talking about
politics in the comment below to tell me
how bad I am so anyway that's no man you
have a perfect life but you can't share
it with anyone so I'll leave that one up
to you which one would you
we're not did we will you press the
button let me know down in the comments
below if you would if you enjoyed this
video please let me know I actually love
doing this because it's interesting
thought experiment and it's pretty fun
too
so let me know if you want to see more
down the comments below let me know if
you enjoyed this video as well thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next we and
what did you end up with I like what do
I even say play it back for me you know
who on me